once all the the Christmas songs start
coming on the first thing I can think it
was like when are we gonna get to
January 2nd like can it all be over soon
I I'm Matt and my parents got divorced
when I was 8 years old now I know no two
divorces are the same but if there's any
time of year that unifies people with
divorced parents it's the holidays and
the fact that they're pretty complicated
so I asked some of my co-workers with
divorced parents to share some of their
experiences and feelings towards the
holiday season and how it's changed from
when they were kids to now as adults um
Logan my parents got divorced when I was
about five years old I'm Jamie I'm 27
my parents divorced when I was five my
name's Lindsey I was 21 when my parents
got divorced my name is al I am
currently 27 years old and I was 6 years
old when my parents got divorced so I'm
Emily I was 4 when my parents got
divorced I'm Chelsea my parents got
divorced when I was like 8 or they got
separated when I was like 8 or 9 and
then I didn't officially get divorced I
was 15 because shits messy I don't
really remember them together at all
which means I only really know spending
Christmas with both of them I mean I had
two Christmases it never really affected
Christmas other than the fact that I had
a lot of extra presents now that they're
divorced and I'm an adult
the holidays are extremely inconvenient
in a weird way I feel fortunate because
I was so young and it's you know when
you're that age like things don't feel
weird like that's just your family and
that's just her day-to-day life the
holidays were weird because like I never
I didn't have memories from when they
were together so I always thought that
people like would go to one house one
year and then another house another year
and then I grew up and was like wait the
biggest thing I think in retrospect
they're like I really
wanted to do was like maintain
traditions
I do have memories of being like well
like my dad's not part of Christmas
anymore like who's gonna fill my mom
stocking give her like pajamas and Santa
presents as you get older having
divorced parents sucks because you
essentially have to pick like one parent
I have had a lot of step parents over
the years five to be exact so just
rolling between two households driving
and staying sober at one or the other
which is hard enough as it is without
divorced parents it's always better to
have like more support around you
growing up as a child I think but I was
really happy that they were both happy
now I kind of don't like the holidays
because it's just it makes me feel tired
I guess if you're dating or in a
relationship with someone who also has
divorced parents it really sucks then
you have for parents to deal with and
you essentially have to choose one of
them and you feel like you're always
gonna hurt someone's feelings
essentially when I was growing up we had
like exciting fun big holidays big
Italian family everyone in one place
usually in my hunt in my parents home
and so now that's that's different and a
lot less fun the one thing that is cool
about having two separate families
during the holidays is that you get to
spend a lot of time with your siblings
kind of bonding over the same shared
weird experience that you're all going
through it like started being okay when
we just kind of stopped trying to
combine it and
in any way and like I'd have like lunch
or something with my dad if you have
siblings it's just a giant mess so when
you're young it's cool to have two
Christmases usually get older it becomes
really complicated I actually love
Christmas I've never disliked it I put
my tree up two days after Thanksgiving
this year but I haven't spent Christmas
with family since 2009 yeah it is a
little weird to juggle your time and
like keeping two sides of the family
separate so I don't know I guess it is
it is normal to feel like you have to
sacrifice from your personal desires to
do things that are right for your family
members and everybody's comfortable into
space like when you're kid you're just
super sheltered and you like again just
don't really realize what's not normal
so I think growing up that kind of
clicked being like oh I don't have to do
this anymore like I don't have to spend
all my time worrying about like family
matters and all that stuff and I guess I
just chose to be indifferent about the
holidays I could just like ignore all
the problems if we just separated it and
we're trying to like bounce around the
holidays now we're kinda like a mixed
bag because it's nice to see parents
that you don't see all the time when
you're an adult
especially if you don't live in the same
state as them but it really just becomes
like a scheduling nightmare trying to
figure out things because you don't get
a lot of time off but you want to see
your parents have a good relationship
with my family I call them I talk to
them
but we're not very celebratory together
the general feeling I have of my parents
divorce is like a feeling of like I
think it was the right thing and I think
I benefited growing up from that choice
I don't know it's hard it's complicated
I guess I think as an adult I I feel
like there I feel like especially
because I live 3,000 miles away from
home and what so when I go home I want
to see like also my friends and like
balancing that with seeing like my
extended family you kind of feel like a
child that sometimes it's like whoa I
was with mom last year this year I have
to be with dad once all the the
Christmas songs start coming on the
first thing I can think it was like when
or
gonna get to January 2nd like can its
all be over soon
I've always liked tradition which i
think is why I haven't minded that I
haven't spent Christmas with family
because I've started my own traditions I
usually spend it with friends yeah in
the long run I think like holidays are
such a small part of what it is to be a
family so I wouldn't say I'm jaded about
the holidays like I think it's
appropriate to call me a Grinch or
whatever but like there's so many other
moments to share with my family that
Christmas or Easter or whatever isn't
really like the biggest part that I feel
bringing us together yeah I think that
everything I've said wouldn't offend my
mom so that's good
[Music]